people are always asking what the hell
is bitcoin for what are the actual use
cases in a real world scenario well over
the weekend we got a perfect example
there's about eight million dollars over
10 million dollars in canadian that was
raised for the freedom convoy for all
those truckers that are now sitting in
ottawa all that money was put forward
through gofundme but all of a sudden
gofundme after getting pressure from the
local government and police force went
ahead and froze the funds these means
that millions of people around the world
who decided that they were going to
donate and give money to the truckers
and their cause
all of a sudden a centralized third
party said no we are going to censor
your payment we're going to censor your
donation we're not going to actually
deliver it to your intended end and so
ultimately this proves exactly why
bitcoin was created bitcoin is a
censorship resistant payment technology
and so what you can see is that
immediately the truckers pivoted and
they started to actually raise money in
bitcoin now of course they haven't been
able to raise nearly as much as they
were through dollars or the canadian uh
currency but instead what they have seen
is the value of bitcoin bitcoin is the
ability for anyone to send money to
anyone else in the world without asking
permission of any centralized platform
or any third party gofundme can't stop
them a government can't stop them a
police force can't stop them bitcoin is
a peer-to-peer network elon musk jumping
into the fray here with a great meme
saying it's not my money the amateur
thieves they steal small things
professional thieves they just steal
millions of dollars instead of allowing
the donations to go through no matter
where you stand on the case of bitcoin
this is a perfect example whenever there
is censorship that goes on whenever
there is the prevention of people doing
what they want with their own money
bitcoin is the solution quite literally
bitcoin fixes this and if the truckers
want to raise money something tells me
that they're going to start accepting
bitcoin and more and more people around
the world are going to realize bitcoin
is the solution
this is the orange pill moment for
millions of people globally